[Musique]
et
huit secondes c'est le temps qui
apparaissent chacun des visages des
victimes du coronavirus dans la petite
ville de bergame en lombardie
[Musique]
la région industrielle détient le triste
record de la plus endeuillée d'italie
avec la moitié des morts à elle seule un
bref hommage
il faut pourtant une journée et demie
pour que défilent la photo de chacun des
milliers de ceux qui ont été emportés
par la maladie
mikari ce poster ici et met à l'après
guerre à la musica que sémou statines
grado dit d'arrêt elle de l'ordre les
familiers canado vitaux sanitaires et
leurs parents et leurs amis ichi cnce a
apporté à la compagnie née la mort tu es
et les funérailles
daniela tao qui est à l'origine de ce
mémorial et les responsables des pages
nécrologiques au quotidien l'écho du
bergamo ses chroniqueuses de la mort n'a
pas tout de suite saisi que son ami lé
s'abattre sur sa petite ville médiévale
au middle with you dans l'appentis
d'habitat dîner et hao minutes avant
qu'almeida you personnellement des noms
n'ont porté vos avec la capitale
en mars c'est une cinquantaine de
personnes qui mouraient en moyenne
chaque jour une inflation cruel
anna a pu accompagner son mari pour son
dernier repos cimetière de bergame avec
leur fils une exception alors que les
morgues et les églises empilait les
morts sans pouvoir les enterrer
mais comme tous ceux qui ont perdu un
être cher de l'aco vide
elle souffre terriblement de ne pas
l'avoir accompagné dans ses derniers
jours
il les aura passé seul dans un centre de
soins pour personnes âgées à qui rudy
mater leader des locaux rattachés à
l'école des prix toujours des abandons à
recoller système allait il te déployé un
dispositif
milena patelli souffle un peu mieux
aujourd'hui
l'infirmière aux soins intensifs de
l'hôpital papa giovanni de bergame
elle s'est retrouvée aux premières loges
d'une tragédie qui allait carrément la
dépasser avec ses collègues
la première nuit où je travaille et je
rentrais des vacances aux mains libres
on à être le fassions corinne qu'il faut
soigner c'était le tout premier qu'on
avait dans ce service
alors j'ai des collègues qui pleurait
donc je me suis dit ok autres je suis à
rentrer et on était renfermé c'était
dans mes pensées je disais c'est moi le
virus c'est le patient est donc je me
suis dit on va bien voir qui va sortir
d'ici
les cas se sont rapidement enchaînés
jusqu'à épuiser les ressources du centre
hospitalier dans une lettre collective
treize des médecins de l'hôpital dénonce
alors une épidémie hors de contrôle où
les personnes les plus âgées ne sont pas
réanimer et meurt seul et l'hôpital
lui-même est hautement contaminée la
moyenne d'âge des patients qu'on a un
post-it alizés ici c'était maximum 65
ans j'ai pas vu des patients plus âgés
que ça c'est sûr il y avait pas les
moyens pour tous donc en bas il avait
quand même sélectionné entre humains et
patient qui vous pouvez être soigné aux
soins intensifs qu'ils auraient pu à la
limite passer le cap en fait là il
salvetat j'ai tenté personnes et sert de
nouveau toit d'une ferme hier son sa
terreur lié à gijon logiquement vers
notre personnel que c'est safari tampon
main lors aux riches qui arrivent sur
nos rives
quant au reste et castanier à ces mises
à chercher son air la pandémie faisais
déjà des ravages en silence à bergame
son médecin de famille lui a
diagnostiqué une simple grippe
le paracétamol conseiller n'a été
d'aucun secours et début mars
il a dû être conduit d'urgence à
l'hôpital il y est resté deux mois avec
la peur au ventre de ne pas en sortir
vivant et mauro facci long et difficile
il passe en force ou la cause a nommé
traumat à calais jean pierre puyal
restait finalement rentré chez lui à
retrouver ses enfants mais il a du mal à
les soulever pour les prendre dans ses
bras
en fait le moindre effort me fatigue il
a vaincu la qu'ovide né sait c'est
qu'elle reste avec la dorna me permets
semaine encore pas m'associer me faire
tripoter re mourir pour difficulté mais
sont ni tarification par continent par
la commutation bergama prend doucement
respirer de nouveau avec prudence
la douleur ici ne passera pas mais la
ville martyre est prête à se tourner
vers l'avenir à sublimer la douleur pour
dessiner la presse